hi it's riya today a friend will be
challenging me to take a popular food
and make it fancy today's guest is kali
what's up brie it is i possibly one of
your favorite people i don't know how
you can reinvent the wheel with takis
and make something that's so good better
but if i know anything is for certain i
know that the sun will come up tomorrow
and i know that riya will continue to
kill it so i'm so excited to see what
you come up with
takis i have had takis before a lot of
people said don't eat too much because
you get acid reflux the lime is the
key component it's very addictive
oh
yeah tacky spiciness comes right at you
it's spicy but i kind of disappeared so
you kind of want to keep eating
i like the flavor so i kind of want to
keep this flavor combination because
spicy and limey is very delicious and
color is
very bright red so i think it's going to
be interesting if we can use this red
color i want to make this a meal more
than just a snack my fingers are red i
forgot to bring my lipstick so maybe
as always i'm excited to make it fancy
alright here's what i got lime red onion
masa micro greens shrimp cilantro orange
avocado there's one more lime lemon
sparkling water crema and garlic from
the pantry i got vegetable oil sugar
flour white vinegar simple syrup salt
baking powder and dragon fruit powder
alright let's get started
make it fancy
first step one and a half cup water half
cup sugar two teaspoon of salt four
smashed garlic 20 takis bring this to a
boil and steep this for about 10 minutes
i think this is a great thing for
halloween it's like i'm poaching bones
and blood maybe next year i'm gonna just
cook this in front of my house it has
been simmering for about 10 minutes i'm
going to strain over red onion let it
pickle at least one hour cut avocado the
pit i think i saw alex's instagram story
you kind of hold and push
perfect i think i heard a lot of people
get injured hacking and twisting i think
this tick tock hack is very useful add
in a blender quarter cup of crema one
tablespoon of lemon juice one garlic
quarter cup of cilantro a little bit
water first so it's going to blend
smoothly and i'm going to blend until
buy blonde green do you know what
japanese people call avocado morino bata
it eats butter from forest right crema
looks great out in a bowl and we are
moving on to next step two cups of
turkeys bring on the food processor
put this in a bowl i'm adding two
tablespoons of ground
half cup of masa harina one tablespoon
of dragon fruit powder just for the
color quarter teaspoon of salt mix it up
oh this is beautiful add a quarter cup
of warm water to start and i'm going to
keep adding as needed
1962 1999. wow so it's a recent
invention
i came to
new york in 2007 so me and otaki were in
america very similar time we are both
immigrants although it's coming together
so i'm going to use my hand this is so
pretty the texture should be like
play-doh it's slightly wet but it's not
sticky we are going to cover this and
let it sit in room temperature about one
hour but we have plenty things to do now
it's a little bit farmer and i'm going
to divide it into four
and make it like a golf sized ball
another torture device
put parchment paper on the bottom
another parchment paper and press it
beautiful
i used tortilla press but if you don't
have it at home you can roll it up with
rolling pin cook this in a pan since
this tortilla looks so pretty i will
cook one minute per side i don't want to
make any brown or burnt color do you
remember the first time
i just remember he is so sweet and nice
to everyone i always wanted to be friend
with him he brought his grandma for a
tasty shoe he was holding her hand and
one of my cooker had a fake cockroach on
the desk i think it was close to
halloween or something and carrie just
like quietly hide it because like she he
didn't want to scare her i thought it
was so cute okay i see a little bubble
and i think it's ready i want to keep
this warm and i don't want to break it
so i'm going to put under the blanket i
always wanted to make this my dream came
true i'm not using oil because it's a
non-stick pan this looks cooked put this
here keep it warm i'm going to finish
making tortillas and i'm gonna move on
i'm heating up oil to 350 while oil is
heating i'm going to make butter one cup
of flour quarter cup of takis this is
the powder i made earlier half teaspoon
of baking soda half teaspoon of salt mix
when i make this dish i usually use beer
but since cauli doesn't drink i'm using
sparkling water you don't want to over
mix it just like lightly mix
i have eight shrimps peeled and debate
seasoned shrimp with salt koto is flour
stretch is in butter it's kind of look
like a white stick medicine pepto bismol
and i'm going to fry
and i don't want to overcrowd
my oil so i'm going to fry maybe four at
the time
wow
it kind of looked like a giant cheetos
too the sparkling water kind of gives
nice airy texture shrimp cooks very
quickly so i'm just cooking about two
minutes when the oil bubbles start
coming and shrimp
it's floating on the surface it's ready
it's cute but if somebody who is eating
this for the first time they couldn't
guess this is a shrimp it's basically a
tempura because tempura you want to use
seltzer water and i think yeah the
baking soda also gives nice fluffy
texture too all shrimp are fried but we
have some more things to do leftover
takis powder adding flaky salt toss a
little bit glass
using lime we are making
mocktail put the glass upside down
and
kind of run
the rip oh it's
so cute so festive i'm gonna add ice
each glass
ice in a shaker
two ounces of orange juice one orange
lemon juice three ounce of lime juice
and shake it
oh it's icy if you're making margarita
obviously you have to add tequila you
usually use triple sec but triple
secrets also has alcohol in it so i used
orange juice instead i'm topping off
with sparkling water and use slime as a
garnish all right drinks are done and
time to move on put tortilla on the
plate first i'm adding avocado crema
spread it using spoons back the shrimp
pickled onion and some micro greens
and i have some crema in a squeeze
bottle top with cilantro
since we have some leftover tacky salt
going to sprinkle
and we are done
[Music]
shrimp takis tacos very
[Music]
fancy i
don't know where you may have used the
takis but i'm assuming it's in the
tortilla yes i made a tortilla
with takis yeah i also made a margarita
virgin mocktail i just went to a
restaurant and i was like hi could i get
a mocktail and they were like we're out
of mock
no
um
no
and she had no idea what i was saying
somebody had to be like virgin
oh yeah
oh my god this is truly one of the best
tacos i've ever had oh my gosh this is
so i'm from l.a born and raised in
hollywood i'm from l.a hands down's one
of the best i've ever had yes
thank you savory man wow cheers
yes how are you this perfect
do you think that i can make this of
course it's easy our lord and savior
really
we have one last thing to do one two
three fancy
[Music]
you